j'ai un rapport un peu contrastée à ce
film que moi j'appelle un ovni et jeu
avant d'aller plus loin je voulais
savoir vous qui êtes un génie de la mode
on peut le dire ce que c'est vrai a dû
l'exode très jeune avant que j'aille un
peu plus loin parce que je vais être un
peu critique pardonnez moi mais c'est
près de congés vous je suis ce rapport à
la critique quand on était adulé depuis
le début très jeune imbrication peu de
recul pour l'accepter la comprendre et
une question et la cueillir sa valeur
chaque variation ambiance ça veut dire
que j'entends parler clairement avec
vous je suis très curieux en fait parce
que quand le film est sorti c'était
alors oui je suis adulte dans la mode
mais j'ai aussi des critiques très bonne
et très mauvaise enfin il faut c'est la
réalité quand on fait une collection on
doit s'appeler ou s'appelait pas non ça
c'est la réalité de mon job
après sur le sur ce que vous dites être
un ovni c'est exactement le mot que
anissa bonne font la réserve chris et
moi on s'est dit quand le documentaire
est sorti parce qu'en fait on s'est dit
les gens comment ils vont réagir déjà
vous pouvez pas me juger comme un alors
c'est pour ça que je vous en jeu vous
j'anticipe pardon je ne crois pas mais
n'ont peut-être pas mais je sais pas moi
j'avais en fait j'avais peur de me dire
si les gens critiquent sur ça ils vont
critiquer ma vie parce qu'ils peuvent
pas jouer critiquer mon talent d'acteur
parce que c'est pas de la 2e manche je
joue pas ma fille
voilà votre équipe et ce qu'ils aimeront
comment ces films et pas filmer je ne
sais pas moi j'avais plus peur pour la
mode parce que vous avez montré dans une
maison de luxe française d'où vous venez
de cette façon là et montre aussi
l'humilité de mes parents de mes grands
parents et ne pas montrer de finalement
le col côté strass et paillettes c'est
aussi un risque que je prends dans mon
propre métier qui fait qui vend du rêve
donc ça serait courageux c'est vrai vous
montrer tous les aspects de votre vie
moi ce qui m'a gêné parce qu'on s'est
présenté comme un documentaire vous
partez à la recherche de votre mère
biologique et sur le temps passant on ne
doute ni de votre sincérité ni votre
souffrance la france 4 qui doit être la
vôtre
ce qui est gênant c'est que ce à la fois
un documentaire espèce de biopic alors
vous êtes encore très jeune et c'est une
mise en abyme qui moi m'a dérangé parce
que ça altéré ma perception de votre
sincérité où on voit olivier rousteing
se contemple en s'écoutant se regardant
aller chercher sa mère et se trouve ça
un petit peu trop haute
je trouve cette affectation qui pour moi
a gêné un peu la lecture et jeux le
point 2 par mois qui ma jeunesse au tout
début documentaire vous êtes dans la
voiture avec votre chauffeur avec une
pelle mon nouveau costume de travail à
la mode et vous du temps je vais te
confier quelque chose je le dis à
personne tu mesures ne pas le répéter
juste avec caméra on est là et vous
dites vous est confiée gérer une ma mère
biologique c'est rien que ce point m'a
gêné et le seul moment je me sens la
bonne foi mais chroniqueur un jeu je le
précise ce fait c'est un avis on ne sait
mais je suis pas là pour rené laporte xp
sinon on dit on fait la géographie des
documentaires et peut on pense à eux
seuls moments où il faut être sincère et
c'est là où j'ai trouvé que le film
était pas ambigu c'est quand on est
effectivement vous êtes avec cette
personne de la dass qui commencent à
vous dire voilà votre maman vous appelez
votre prénom c'est pas su la vie pendant
et là vous avez une émotion sincère que
se compare en effet aux accusés moore
qu'il faut c'est son plus long et là
vous cachez vous cacher mon village et
pour moi c'est seulement de sincérité de
ce film et je voulais en parler avec
vous n'est ce pas un peu paradoxal que
ça non mais c'est complet
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais vous avez entièrement raison dans
le dans la façon de juger ce afin de le
voir parce que vous savez vous avez dit
la preuve ils apprennent les premiers
mois important c'est un biopic et c'est
très rare d'avoir un biopic a donc c'est
pas cohérent
vous faites un documentaire sur laquelle
votre mère ou un biopic nom a bien fait
pas c'était c'était l'histoire de
retracer ce que je vis aujourd'hui ma
vie au fil des saisons est à la fois
dense est blanchi des saisons de la mode
la recherche
ma recherche biologique qui n'a pas du
tout été anticipée parce qu'on ne
pouvait pas avoir les réponses pendant
ces deux ans et demi et je tiens aussi à
dire bravo à la réalisatrice parce que
nous sommes en fait à nice à bonnefont
parce qu'elle aurait pu commencer ce
film sans avoir aucune fin et se dire
finalement cette quête qui pour moi
était personnelle on n'aurait peut-être
pas pu aller jusqu'au bout parce que on
n'aurait pas eu des réponses
il ya des bouts il ya beaucoup de biopic
qui sort de deux designers cantons où
ils sont morts ils sont fins de carrière
et ça c'est des documentaires qui sont
scriptés sur l'année passée
et celui-là était pas du tout script et
parce que parce qu'en fait on ça l'est
parce qu'on savait pas ce qui allait se
passer et ça c'était important après si
vous trouvez pas de piètres sincérité
dans ce documentaire
j'ai dit que c'était faux dans la scène
est très sincère justement belle affaire
doit être sincère vous cacher parce que
vous c'est trop dur c'est trop c'est
trop
mais excusez moi mais comment vous
cachez enfin je découvre qu'elle a 14
heures alors oui j'arrive plus
facilement à moi me cacher quand je dis
je suis seul parce que j'avoue j'assume
j'ai c'est un travail sur moi même que
j'ai fait pendant deux ans et demi c'est
un documentaire que vous voyez faire
1h40 mais c'était deux ans et demi de
film donc deux ans et demi à tourner ça
veut dire que j'ai aussi dû apprendre à
ne plus voir les caméras abandonné les
caméras je les oublie pas comme celle ci
qui est maintenant là que j'entends
jusqu'à ce tir a mûri à côté de moi mais
abandonnée si vous avez une caméra
pointée 24 heures sur 24 ça devient
votre allié